five minutes after the hour president
biden getting a dire warning about the
midterm elections from his own party and
democrats are calling on the
administration to change its messaging
immediately or face a red wave in
november alexandria hoff joins us live
at the white house alexandria
well good morning guys by staying the
course they are on the administration is
hanging fellow democrats out to dry that
is according to democratic strategist
michael stratton who told the daily mail
quote democrats need to you know wake up
here smell the coffee and start to get
ready and there he's talking about the
midterms of course where voters are
considering things like the border
crisis wavering coveted policies
sky-high food and gas prices historic
inflation we have mortgage rates that
just now hit five percent but on these
costs the white house is sticking to
this putin's price hike branding take a
listen
we understand some realities happening
right now including the fact that there
is a war happening in europe and that is
dominating the airwaves which we
understand and fully expect and so
the president has actually done a number
of events on the economy in recent days
and weeks
and will continue to
but that hasn't moved the needle at
least not in the direction the president
would like according to the latest
quinnipiac university poll just 33
percent of americans approve of his
performance here is former clinton
campaign adviser mark penn
these are spectacularly low numbers
to really get down to only a third being
favorable and in the 20s on independence
of course makes re-election of virtual
impossibility the the the administration
has got to pivot
or this is going to be a tornado of the
midterms
added stress to the holiday weekend
that's for certain and the president is
spending it at camp david pete rachel
bryan
wow we'll see if the white house feels
that five alarm fire that mark penn uh
talks about uh thanks so much that was
andrew when the only explanation you
have is we're just not selling it well
enough right like you're always at the
bottom of the barrel if only people knew
how great we were they just
can't hear it through all the press
other than fox which is still trying to
prop them up yeah you know it's
interesting because we are talking about
the politics of it on the midterms and
all that stuff but i think about the
district that i lived in um just a year
ago a working class district people are
in a lot of pain right people seriously
are are not able to buy the amount of
groceries they need to feed themselves
old people on fixed income struggling
people going i can't put my kid in in a
sport or a camp this summer i can't even
afford to put the gas in to drive him to
the soccer games this is happening
around the country and i just think that
the administration is really
just absolutely toned after this
absolutely insensitive right there's a
couple of things coming out of the
pandemic you could understand there
might be supply chain problems for the
first time in 100 years we stopped
doing anything remember we we stopped
everybody stopped their economy and then
we haphazardly restarted it as a wave
would hit this nation australia another
wave would hit canada another wave would
hit china okay i understand that but
there was no urgency to fix it there was
all urgency to sell it differently and
your transportation secretary takes
three months paternity leave at the most
inopportune time and they didn't even
tell us and so there's there's inflation
starts to rise and you told us it will
be temporary and at the border you just
knew you didn't like donald trump's plan
but you had no plan all those things
you had uh control over if inflation was
going to go up as the economists say
coming out of this pandemic did it have
to go up to 8.5 i'm looking at the 1980s
it was up to 11 and then to try to get
it down they raised interest rates so
now interest rates were at five percent
oops i'm gonna get my first time house
don't think so or i was gonna remortgage
doesn't make sense anymore that affects
the banks so the ripple effects so you
like to think that you might hear from
janet yellen with the fed experience as
treasury secretary you might think that
you are going to hear a little bit more
from the transportation secretary as we
talk about the price of uh jet fuel and
why it's so uh why it's not affordable
to fly anymore but you don't you see the
president out making a speech and then
disappearing shaking hands with the air
did you see that
video yesterday that was very sad
actually it was i mean there needs to be
an intervention with this family it's
just really i'm not i say that with with
full compassion i thought that was
really
painful to watch i felt bad for him
right
i feel bad for us
right thank you thank you
i'm steve ducey i'm brian killman and
i'm ainsley earhart and click here to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
to catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis